hello my name is Mandy I was a middle
and high school teacher for six years hi
I'm Vanessa and I've been a preschool
teacher for twelve years my name is
Salani and I am a science teacher I've
been so for five years now hi my name is
Stephanie and I've been a teacher for
three years and today we are guessing
teens legs
[Applause]
[Music]
what is it about demon I don't fully
know it but I've heard of a gust cloud
adjacent terminology let's do that like
a criminal here's something like I have
no idea something evil something not to
be you're trying to Sabbath sabotage
somebody's Instagram popularity I don't
know for sure but I imagine it's some
sort of evil misuse of notoriety okay
Klout is like trying to get like
notoriety I guess so a cloud demon maybe
somebody that I'm really obsessed with
being popular I'm gonna get oh that's a
good guys now that you explained what
cloud man I can kind of yeah I'm gonna
go with like popularity demon
oh right okay what's that too far off
they do anything for club they do any
thats all i somebody trying to get be
bigger than they actually are to show
show off almost or i don't know i know
i've heard this before
i know a glow office globe is like when
you start out not so cute and then you
finally grow up and you're like amazing
and you floss on everybody and let them
know how amazing you are or you like
look beautiful or maybe they get their
makeup done I don't know that's what I
was thinking
yeah yeah like like you got a makeover
glow up them or your life got a makeover
basically you you grew up - not a glow
up as kind of like a positive
transformation so if you're looking back
at your awkward middle school years and
it looks so much better now you've
achieved a glow up to look the way you
do now
[Music]
they're strapped like you're trying too
hard like you're thirsty for something
you're like you're really like you're
tried too hard
somebody who's thirsty for something
trying to oh if you're thirsty you're
wanting something you're wanting more
attention a thirst trap is when people
post pictures that are like attracting
certain types of attention usually
half-naked boys will like be half naked
or girls we have negative things okay so
I like you know get you to go to their
page for whatever reason so they could
sell you some tea I don't know I usually
not proud to be doing so it's kind of
embarrassing so it's when you post a
picture on Instagram that like is
provocative and the intent of posting
this is to get thirsty dudes into your
DMS so yeah I don't know cuz I don't do
that yeah your tea f/w SFW is it like
though I don't know like I don't know
what the I don't know if W is on either
I need help guys yeah thanks for I think
it's the face one and it's like the face
when and then you can fill in the blank
and it's like a mean thing like the face
when you have to eat gross school
lunches at BuzzFeed and
[Laughter]
I had that also Wow
that feeling win but I don't let more
innocent that out so I know I'm all
thinking it something really bad sis
well now I know
[Music]
Jomo know something similar to FOMO I'm
guessing but you change change word
I know FOMO fear of missing out jealousy
is missing out yeah Jomo no mom joy no
joy of missing out joy of joy of missing
out actually recently heard this one boy
I'm missing out is that a good thing
yeah because like you're you're like oh
I don't want to go to that party oh my
god I don't care
jealous admitting that I don't know that
was my guess you're very much on the
right track but this is the joy of
missing out like when I choose to stay
in bed instead of going out to that
crazy party that's how I totally feel
Jomo absolutely
receipts like a receipt like CBS like
the really long ones I have a bunch in
my purse I'm sure that's not what this
is so it's not so it it's screenshots of
anything happening that you can kind of
use as proof if somebody delete
something you have the receipts I guess
I have some of those after all I know a
receipt sorry oh you do oh oh come on
let's go ahead oh um no I'm like uh you
read that like you know get like a read
receipt how was that am i way off I mean
I could I could be wrong I think
receipts are like proof of something
like say somebody was talking okay and
then I got receipts and then you show
them your phone and they text a
screenshot of it or something
it's like proof but it's a lot more
sense than my explanation
[Music]
oh my lord
boys are we speaking right now I think I
know I'm not cool you don't feel so much
cooler right now
no out of substance did he just I feel
like I know I feel like that's like it's
a girl Jack ulation word its Yi ting on
their face I've heard that and I had to
regulate I think it has something to do
with like an expression of excitement
and I think you can like eat yourself
off a cliff that's like the usage I've
seen it for it what is he I thought
really what it means I mean that's what
I heard okay though I think it's a
little more innocent than that right I
very damn wrong yeah my class Oh God I'm
wrong oh Jesus okay okay
[Music]
trill do you know that
oh I've totally heard this I know I've
heard it used I just nope nope I'm dried
of like I've heard that word in a rap
song that trill trill
cool I don't know I don't know trill
noisy I'm starting to doubt myself on
this but I believe that it's like
genuine like true and real like I was
true that means that it's not fake I
didn't even guess so good job haha I'm
not even guessing babe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I feel like a totally uncool teacher
like granny over here knows none of the
slang and part of me is sad but then
party is okay with it since I'm not even
a teacher anymore and haven't been for
almost a decade I don't understand why I
know this I don't even watch TV so I
don't understand okay this is coming
from and I want to naturally hips see I
don't know the new term for hip like rad
very naturally right I'll take that I
mean yeah I learned a lot I didn't know
a few of them and now I'll be paying
extra attention for some of those words
I feel like I learned a lot I definitely
am gonna be using the word yeet in a
different way now I'll be here when kids
throw trash across the classroom
[Music]